Bây giờ, sau chuyên tham chính thức tên trư kích thang ngày 1.8,
tồng thống ngà, bởi vì mì pù chiên bài tỏ ủng hộ sáng kến hoa mình,
gió tổng thủng mi đông nên trong khởi sướng, nhằm chấp dứt xuống đột tại giải gà xa.
Tồng thống pù chiên nhận định, nếu kế hoặc này được chín khai thành công,
thì đây sẽ là sự kiện măng tình liệt sương và khẳng định ngà sẵn sáng tham gia tính chiếm hoa giải.
Dờ chiên môi quan hệ tình kệ lâu giải về cơ khú giải đập và palestin.
Lên quan đến tình liệt uống khai nè, tồng thống thu chiên cũng cho biết,
mắt sức bài bà quá trình tình đặc suy chiên kên liệt lạch trong khun cột hoa thỏng đặt đuận.
Tà hội ý tự định Alaskar, huy tháng tham.
Theo chự lý tổng thống ngà, Juri, Yusia Khóc, ngà đa đưa xam xuống nhận bộ,
thể hiện thiện chi tình kiến sẻ khá hòa mình.
Nếu Mỹ có thể thích phục được các đồng mình cho ông và chính quyền kếp tham xa.
Dờ qua xa nhận định, những tuy bôn này và lãnh bước đi chín nơ của ngà,
nhằm cùng có vị thế của tế và mở giọc đứa thay cho bước cạnh cảnh trên định chiến này cảnh cây khát.